Ohio Governor John Kasich served in
Congress during a government shutdown
back in 1995 he was also chairman of the
House Budget Committee three years later
when the country balanced the budget for
the first time in decades Kasich was the
last Republican standing against Donald
Trump in the Republican primary race in
2016 he delivered a speech during his
campaign that he called two paths to
distinguish himself from his opponents
to pass one choice the path that
exploits anger encourages resentment
turns fear into hatred and divides
people the other path is a one America
has been down before 12 trod yeah it's
at times it's very steep but it's also
solid now that speech inspired the title
the governor's new book it's called two
paths America divided or United he joins
us now at the table governor it's good
to have you back god I look so young I
mean what happened to me I used to be
young you are still you know was Charlie
yo me about still look good though he's
young two years from now you believe
that historians will scratch their heads
and look at this election as a tipping
point what will they see there was
completely nuts people yelling and
screaming and making wild promises and
tearing each other down I mean I'd stand
on the edge of the stage and just shake
my head and I couldn't believe that
people the people watching we're just
not outraged and then of course you
folks would take these clips and the
more incendiary they were the more you
would play them and it was just a bad
outcome and i think i think frankly a
lot of people in the media have regrets
about the way in which they covered the
race and I don't know if the politicians
do tell you the other thing that's so
funny is that people people don't think
that when you're in politics and you
have principles that they're real so
what I wouldn't endorse Trump or go to
the convention people are like well you
know he's bitter or angry the farthest
thing from that you said it's just a
Marv sure to go to the convention I know
you were pressured my words mean
something to me yeah and when somebody
was pulling somebody down I'm not going
to go for them I'm not going for any
candidates in either party they're going
to seek to divide us including my own
party we can't have that anymore in this
country and look it's not just
politicians it's all of us we've got to
get our act together and realize these
other human beings that we may not agree
with are decent and good people we all
listen to them a little bit well you're
7 a-11 point that's right here and we
talked about this week based on your
experience do you think we'll have a
government shutdown no because no one
wants one and I think the people who are
way out there and want to be destructive
I think they would not be listened to
the question is can they pull some of
the Democrats they have to to be able to
support continuation of the government I
suspect it will be worked out you said
you never thought that Donald Trump
would win but he won and that we should
listen to that well look I mean there
are a lot of people hurting out there
people who lost their jobs are on the
verge of losing their jobs or they're
not making any money I get those people
I grew up in that environment and so we
have to give them hope which you can't
tell them is it somebody else's fault
that you you're in the position you're
in we have to deal with you and we have
to get you up on your feet and give you
hope that tomorrow will be a better day
if we don't do that the political system
grinds down but look we think about the
political system and then we look at
United Airlines and we see normal human
beings yanking some guy off of an
airplane I mean what were people
thinking you know so we have to unite
ourselves because if we continue to be
divided we're not going to make progress
as a nation or as a culture your party
and the republican party controls the
legislative and the executive branch
it's incredible opportunity to put in
place a lot of changes that that
conservatives would like the repeal of
Obamacare specifically Medicaid
expansion you've taken put that into
place in Ohio if they repeal that what
would happen they would devastate people
in my state now there is a way to fix
all of this and I don't think there's
anybody that doesn't think that
Obamacare can't be improved the
exchanges there's ways in which you can
fix the Medicaid Medicaid expansion but
the funny thing is it's gotten so bad
that when the republicans took over they
never thought about talking to Democrats
nothing big ever can be sustained if you
don't have both parties working with it
whether it's the balanced budget act of
97 whether it's reforming welfare you
have to have people working together in
that
place now here's the other thing these
politicians I swear they think they're
going to be there forever they're not
going to be there forever and so what
are you doing to improve the world while
you're there and again everybody wants
to only focus on politics what about
EpiPen jacking up their prices and
hurtin families what about Wells Fargo
filing false accounts see Charlie we
look all of you we have to remember the
values our mothers and fathers taught us
and carry them through life because life
is short and we will be measured at the
end of our lives by what we did not by
what title we had or how much money we
had you say it's not a question of
leadership in this country it's a
question of followship a new word you
made up well you need you need no you
need great leaders but you need
followers and if the leaders not going
to take you to a better place why are
you following and if the leader gets off
track it's important for you to say no I
mean if you think about a football team
the coach is the person that kind of
sets the direction but when the coach
leaves it's the players in the locker
room that provide the leadership its
leadership where we all are look people
need to realize they matter I don't care
whether you're the CEO or the person
turning off the lights at night you can
make a difference in the way the world
works and my solution is we find common
humanity everybody's fighting with one
another people can't even have weddings
without fights breaking out okay so
here's what I think people need to work
in a food bank feed the kids everybody's
for that we need to fight the scourge of
drugs everybody's for that we need to
visit the elderly when their spouse dies
this these kinds of things will pull us
together and forget all these big
politicians Martin Luther King didn't
fix America by starting at the top the
politicians wouldn't even meet with him
he drove it at the community level
exposed the moral outrage and we all got
together or they all got together god
bless him and drove change from the
bottom up and United the country and
soon he was in the Oval Office dealing
with Lyndon Johnson about civil rights
legislation yeah he [ __ ] me what look